françois poule et matis journaliste
spécialiste des institutions européennes
et coauteur du livre break site une
chance bonjour françois poulet mathis
merci d'être avec nous ce midi sur rt
france on lisait les britanniques adopte
donc elle ce projet de loi controversé
est ce que cette manoeuvre n'est pas un
pas de plus vers un au deal avec l'union
européenne
c'est possible mais il faut comprendre
que nous sommes dans la dernière phase
de la négociation et comme dans toute
négociation dans la dernière phase
on fait monter les enchères les
britanniques ont frappé fort hier
puisqu'ils ont voté un texte de loi qui
finalement contredit l'accord qu'ils
avaient eux mêmes signés et donc qui
pose une véritable pierre dans la
confiance que l'on peut établir dans les
relations entre les vingt-sept et les
britanniques pour la sortie de l'union
européenne néanmoins tout n'est pas
impossible
il peut encore y avoir des petites
solutions
je lui en donne pour preuve que le fait
que boris johnson ex a accepté hier
qu'un amendement puisse permettre aux
députés britanniques de mettre leur
droit de veto sur cette tête
dispositions de cette loi ce qui
contreviendrait à l'accord préalable
donc on est dans une phase où tout est
possible mais on est dans une phase où
la tension monte
il y a deux phases dans une négociation
il ya la face extérieure dans lequel on
affirme des positions et ses positions
sur une eau plus en plus forte
et puis dans toute négociation il ya ce
qu'on appelle le tunnel le tunnel c'est
quoi c'est le fait de pouvoir engager
des négociations tard en dessous secrète
relativement discrète pour savoir
vraiment dans le fond est ce que les
britanniques veulent un accord ou est ce
qu'ils ne veulent pas d'accord là est la
véritable question est là il est permis
encore aujourd'hui d'avoir un doute sur
les véritables intentions de boris
johnson alors les britanniques avouent
eux-mêmes que cette loi bafoue le droit
international qu'est ce qui a poussé
justement les britanniques à adopter
cette loi ce qui a poussé les
britanniques il faut bien comprendre que
en fait cette loi dite du marché
intérieur c'est une loi qui finalement
quelque part et c'est de s'affranchir
une frontière que d'accord est en train
de mettre en irlande du nord où plus
exactement en mer d'irlande entre l'art
et plus encore l'irlande du nord et le
royaume uni pourquoi parce que
finalement les contrôles que l'on ait
said institué pour faire en sorte qu'il
n'y ait pas de distorsion de concurrence
que ces contrôles soient effectués par
les l'as douanes britanniques entre
l'irlande du nord et la république
d'irlande
tout cela bien sûr pour éviter le
rétablissement d'une frontière physique
entre l'irlande du nord et la thur
république d'irlande là est tout l'enjeu
est donc les britanniques se disent
aujourd'hui on a accepté finalement cet
accord mais cet accord nous oblige
finalement d'une certaine manière à
rétablir une frontière non pas entre
l'irlande du nord à la république
d'irlande
mais ce qui est pire rétablir une
frontière entre d'irlande du nord et le
royaume uni et c'est cela qui finalement
a poussé boris johnson a essayé de jouer
cette carte de poker qui et c'est
vraiment du poker parce que là on joue
vraiment à se faire peur parce que d'une
certaine manière on joue sur la
confiance et cette confiance aujourd'hui
elle a pris un plan de relève vous le
disiez on joue à se faire peur mais
qu'il peut être la réaction justement de
l'union européenne après cette décision
britannique colin sans l'éclair elle
éclaire l'union européenne accepte pas
cette loi qui contredit finalement
l'accord qui a été conclu d'accord de
sortie et surtout l'accord de libre
échange entre l'union européenne et les
donc il n'est pas question d'accepter
ces lois donc l'union européenne a
demandé aux britanniques de retirer
cette loi tout simplement faute de quoi
et finalement il n'y aurait pas d'accord
et donc on se dirigerait vers une
situation de nos 10
encore une fois il peut encore y avoir
des sorties des portes de sortie cesse
d'enrichir ça nous est déjà habitué à ce
genre de chose puisque finalement ils
n'acceptaient pas qui est une solution
intermédiaire pour l'irlande il a
accepté dans l'accord dit de sortie et
aujourd'hui on peut très bien imaginer
que cette loi qui pose un véritable
problème de crédibilité
y compris dans le camp conservateur il
ya un ancien premier vice qui considère
que là on a fait une imprudence qui
risque de coûter très cher
à la crédibilité de la grande bretagne
eh bien peut-être que là dans ces
fameuses négociations tunnel qui sont en
train de s'engager
peut-être qu'il y aurait une sortie
n'est encore tout est incertain pour la
vous le disiez tout à l'heure
l'union européenne et la grande bretagne
entre dans la dernière phase de
négociation il nous reste donc un mois
pour envisager tous les scénarios
que se passera-t-il concrètement si
aucun accord n'est trouvé avant la fin
du mois d'octobre
et ben si aucun accord n'est trouvé à la
fin du mois d'octobre on s'oriente vers
ce qu'on appelle un odile
cela dit les 27 s'y prépare déjà donc
toutes les dispositions sont prises aux
frontières entre l'union européenne et
la grande bretagne pour adapter la
législation pour adapter les douanes qui
doit effectivement se remettre en ordre
de marche
en absence d'accord et bien on se
retrouve finalement dans deux pays qui
se trouve étrangers et qui sont obligés
de renégocier des rapports mais les
renégats sied à chaud ce qui paraît très
difficile et on pense en particulier aux
pêcheurs aux pêcheurs français qui
n'auront plus accès aux eaux
britanniques et aussi aux pêcheurs
britannique qui eux n'auront plus accès
aux marchés de l'union européenne ya ce
domaine là mais il ya aussi tout le
problème des relations et des
possibilités de flux à la frontière qui
seraient stoppés
donc c'est un peu la solution cauchemar
est ce que on en arrivera là toujours
est il que au niveau des 27 c'est vrai
on se prépare aujourd'hui pour le dire
on se prépare à un autre il
merci beaucoup françois poulet mathis
d'avoir été avec nous ce midi sur rt
france rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste et spécialiste des
institutions européennes coauteur du
livre break site une chance aux éditions
hauteur du monde merci beaucoup